right now we're looking for a group of
lions that we had--we in the area when
we locate them want to pass this
information on to the lion engineering
team so that they can come to the area
checking process and prevent any lions
from getting caught and we can't find
them today consequences of a pretty
serious because this area is usually
used by poachers hopefully this is
basically Tyson and whatever body part
you know has been forced to sleep in it
it makes can lead to death cause animals
and jobs to death and/or dead and
effectively if it's a limb that little
can be cut off which hiring freezes in
likelihood that the animal type so much
I'm here nobody healthy in lion he was
in trust but not they actually work
today so he's more difficult to find my
article submissions of opaque after a
couple months of grain so the lion can
be a couple meters from where I am and I
would not be able to see it
because I have to speak up such as a
little hostility
when we get close to the admin say
between 30 or 50 because the signal gets
really strong and it becomes difficult
15 point exactly this way the animals
might be so that means we need to keep
an eye out
oh wow
children between makes a happy end this
line
[Music]